liberty pool for prime minister next
time
i'm liberty from love island i'm kaz
from love island and we're here for
glasgow
[Music]
like the first one that we met was on
the deep in front of me and i was behind
him we was going in and always just knew
straight away that we was going to get
on once we got out
from the minute we walked in he was
literally like yeah that's my girl yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
you like gym guys
i love you you don't like participating
in your town
swimming oh i put cheerleaders
[Laughter]
babe sorry i've got to show me i'll do a
cheerleading
[Laughter]
live in jail oh my
what would your crime be this is gonna
be so far off
okay what did you like oh i put knocking
out my boyfriend for doing them dying
i could see that happening yeah
i said walking out a store like from the
fitting rooms like forgetting to play
i'd probably like walk out the store and
forget to pay because i'm on the right
to knock out my boyfriend between them
yeah so do we both get the point
i just put like
no i actually can't say what i put
bonnet i put
it's really hard looking after wigs in
that villa right i kept jumping into
that pool we had to wear a bunny it was
either that or bad wigs uh-uh oh
oh oh
[Music]
and i oh don't get it
like she said in the villain all of us
were like what is that i've been scarred
for life from some salty lip moments so
you like lads and you kiss them and you
can taste salt because they're sweating
that much when i've kissed them maybe
they didn't and it just so it just don't
attack my pain
with salt and lemon maybe that's why on
the night out okay right so
what's that up for
just me not knowing
[Laughter]
okay so what is your title yeah i put
jamie dawn in fifty shades of grey yeah
if you want my type summarized it is
pretty boy with a bad boy edge so i said
the guy from fifty shades i said jamie d
because i didn't know he's gonna say
he's trying to do we love jbd i don't
want to spell it wrong yeah you're a
pretty boy with a bad boy edge and a
good heart sliding towards the end
no i'm focusing on myself right now but
i might be available in a couple of
months who knows get that slide into my
dms and i'll sort you out all right
i'm trying not to love him too i'll try
i'll look this way
simping oh god crying
it's poisonous
you've got a lot of sass but inside
you're a deep down softie yeah
embarrassing
[Laughter]
come on
oh we had this in that game cars you
really need to know me to know this
i'll put seven a stars and two a's
all i know is you've got loads i've got
nine airs an a star and a b you know so
can you just run it quite
fantastic thank god that asked me about
my gcses and not my levels because that
might be a different story
[Music]
oh
these
yeah it's a problem actually
yeah literally liberty and walpole for
prime minister i'd vote for you
it can't be me i think that i'm good at
i'm always like because it's yeah both
sides are yeah
yeah i do i mean
is
[Laughter]
you you can't be a bit of a scared brian
sometimes can't you i can as well when
he was getting ready on the night there
was always five things that she had
before went down she was ready but that
was always like moisturizing nice part
of yours
now i've got to do this now i've got
earrings yeah and earrings yeah i don't
know
ah i think you're funnier than me okay
i'm not funny oh you know what it is i
think
you're like more witty but i just do
random [ __ ] like you are just funny you
know you're actually just funny it's
just funny
i'm gonna start telling people i'm funny
about guys i'm funny yeah
yeah
i would survive the apocalypse i said
you gotta fall off you'd probably walk
out with the actual zombies yeah i'd
like to try yeah what are you doing yeah
i'd be i'd be gonna
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
but girls
this works this method works a treat you
know
yeah that's it that's me winning thank
you for participating
thanks guys thank you
where's my prize